so this this is exciting because this is
a new episode i don't know this one
i know how many times will we have to
record this one let's find out
[Music]
so i wanted to cover a less technical
topic there we go we just lost
50 percent of our viewers right there
and then but uh
thank you thank you to everyone who
stayed um
because i do think it's an important one
for most developers i want to talk about
interviewing like particularly
interviewing for technical roles
that's a controversial topic isn't it oh
well i'm sure we'll find out in the
comments
if it's controversial or not but yeah i
think
interviewing is really difficult like as
a system
it's unusual imagine that after a speed
dating session you had to send one of
the people you met a marriage proposal
there and then
because that's kind of how interviews
work right you spend
you know they made tv shows out of that
concept right what
the job thing or the marriage thing the
marriage thing
speed dating then marriage that's
interesting isn't it because like yeah
shows like the apprentice they spend a
whole series on it but
like some of these dating shows it is
just like an hour so i guess that is
more realistically like an interview i
think interviewing well as in
i mean interviewing can mean so many
things
it is you know you want you're looking
for someone to add to your business to
your company
and i guess the purpose is figuring out
if
that person that you are considering a
candidate is actually
good for the role and if you are good
for the candidates yeah
exactly yeah you get an hour or two with
them to decide that
and then you pick one and propose that
you enter into a long-term relationship
backed by a contract
there you go job done so i thought i
would give my tips for
interviewing i don't claim to be perfect
at it
um but i've been doing it for a number
of years so these are just my reckons
really um but at google i was given an
award for being
one of the top interviewers which means
the most interviews not the best
interviews
let's yes okay fair enough it was more
than number
but they get me to do that because i'm
because i'm good at them that's what i
tell myself
can you remember what the award was by
the way
do you mean the the yellow helium
balloon star
that's right i got a balloon so and it
lived on your desk
i think for a considerable amount of
time i had that balloon
for uh nine months
i think it was a good balloon it was a
high quality balloon
and even once that balloon started to
drift down
and hit my co-workers in the face and
they said can you get rid of that
i said no that's my balloon
i got it for doing interviews and
keeping it until it hits the floor
that sounds like a little you know jokey
embellishment but that actually happens
like we were all observing the balloon
slight hover slightly lower every day
as it slowly fell to his death and uh
i people thought i got rid of it because
it was gone but what i'd actually done
is put it in the recycling bin
knowing that when someone would open the
recycling bin the balloon would come
back out
uh i'm fun to work with anyway
if you're watching this at home and you
think you know better than me
at interviewing where's your balloon
show me your balloon and then we'll talk
that's what i'm saying
but yeah a lot of this is subjective and
i'm
i'm looking forward to the discussion in
the comments around this and hearing of
the points of views uh provided the
moderators don't delete everything
as they've been doing recently sorry
about that um
but here are my reckons first up i want
to talk about the general
attitude and you hit upon this uh
before you're trying to find the
candidate who's going to be the best
employee for your company uh the best
teammate for you
as well if that's what you're hiring for
my first piece of advice is don't try to
defeat the candidate
and this sounds obvious i see this a lot
uh late the candidate is
competing against other candidates
indirectly they're not
competing against you you're not there
to try and
catch them out there you should try and
be on the candidate's side
like you would with a with a teammate
and i say should because
we know from twitter and youtube
comments
that there are a lot of people who have
the personality of the riddler from
batman you know it's all of that
kind of i am more superior than you
therefore i win
and i just say to people like that grow
up
pack that in and definitely do not take
it into a job interview because it's a
horrible thing to do
um it might seem like i'm late you
implement inheritance just with
functions and manual prototype
manipulation
you don't you fail i've definitely
got that stuff wrong before as well like
what you just said there
i've i've used that question in
interviews and i am embarrassed about it
so i i'm saying stuff
the advice i'm giving here like i say
i'm not perfect it's based on the stuff
that i've got wrong
as well and it might seem like i'm
laboring some of these points but
you watch tv and films and the way
interviews are dramatized there
a lot of people think that's how it's
supposed to be let's take a tech example
a friend of mine interviewed for an
agency in london and as part of the
interview they asked her to take a look
at their
websites their agency sites and you know
suggest things that could be improved
that kind of thing and they had this 404
page
that was this big cute
image you know cute four or four pages
right you've seen them before
but she pointed out that you know their
website has this
consistent nav at the top and at the
bottom
except their 404 page and she's like
well hang on this this could be a
problem
because a 404 is a dead end for the user
like they might have had a misspelled
url or something
and you're you're not giving that nav
that way of
that they could help themselves out so
that there's an improvement
and this didn't sit well clearly with
well the head of design at the company
and during the the q a section
uh launched in with i've got a question
for you
why do you hate delight and i was told
this story five years ago and it still
makes me angry because
it's exactly that you know my friend did
learn from that
experience that there was someone senior
in the company who was
toxic so it kind of dodged a bullet so
it was useful in some ways but
seriously like a candidate is nervous in
an interview situation and they're in an
unfamiliar place so if you're the kind
of person that
takes advantage of that to land some
punches
you're a bully like there's no pride or
honor in that there's no benefit in
doing it
it's a suggestion and i don't think i
also don't think those
two things were mutually exclusive you
could have still left the football phage
cute
with the hat bar and a bottom bar um
and you could i mean it's your opinion
to disagree with the candidate's
suggestion
but you have just enough to justify your
opinion as they have to justify theirs
so in the end it should be an actual
constructive dialogue and i think if
anything as you said
the company failed that interview
themselves then
yeah absolutely my next piece of advice
is uh don't judge the candidate on
unrelated things
and again it's nothing i mean your shirt
is questionable today
i've gone quite bright today uh i
i actually bought this for doing these
recordings because like
every time we've been filming i keep
getting told to wear something brighter
so i actually bought this with recording
in mind which is unusual for you because
you usually wrap the conference shirts
exclusively i usually wear shirts i got
for free
at conferences but turns out conferences
aren't happening right now so i've had
to start
buying clothing sir think of me during
the pandemics
having to buy clothes but yeah don't
judge people on unrelated things and
yeah clothing is one of them but i saw
this twitter thread recently
where someone in the web development
community was saying they judge
candidates on the setup of their code
editor
like an example they gave was the the
kind of syntax highlighting they use
and this is similar to judging people by
clothes and i do have friends in old
tech
who will judge people by the suit they
wear to the interview
and in both cases like syntax
highlighting the suit thing
folks will defend that attitude by
saying well it tends to
correlate with ability or it tends to
correlate with professionalism
in terms of the suit thing but these
things are just feeding into your biases
and if you interview properly
you can actually test for ability you
can actually test for professionalism
you don't have to crystal ball these
things you don't have to read tea leaves
other things because it's it's
inaccurate and it's unfair
yeah i mean statistics rule 101 is
correlation is not the same thing as
causation just because
things correlate doesn't allow you to
look
at the effect and you know imply back
that the cause is also true
i you know i remember that the the core
team
of go the programming language um
you know pretty famous people with um
rob pike and russ cox and similar people
and they all are advocates of
not using syntax highlighting are you
telling me that those people
are not highly productive good engineers
i am
not so sure as you say like don't i mean
the main problem is don't use proxy
metrics don't
if you are in an interview you can as
you just said actually
measure directly whether the
capabilities that you need
are present in the candidate there's no
need to rely on
proxy metrics like this person is not
using the same error as me
therefore bad absolutely
um to give a couple examples of that 10
years ago
i was doing some job interviews and i
took a long
one of those tiny little notebook laptop
things
that were a trend at the time
and i had sublime text on it i didn't
use it often for coding
uh but it was sort of set up it wasn't
set up well but it was possible
and i brought that along with me for
coding interviews and the reason
i use bringing that along with me is it
was the only portable
device i had it was the one that i could
afford i had a desktop machine at home
but this was the one portable device i
could afford could have brought that i
guess
i could have could have brought the
whole desktop unit slammed that down on
the desk and it's like can i get a plug
socket plug socket anywhere
but yeah so so but if it's kind of
horrible to think that someone would
see this tiny laptop and think that
that's how i normally did things or that
that was the
best i could set up an ide and the same
goes with clothing like to most job
interviews i've been to
i'm wearing what i was wearing for my
job
my job at the time because if i turned
up for work
with a suit there's only so many times
that i can say
you know wedding or funeral it's like
well what is it today oh it's a funeral
this time
yeah it's a funeral for the person that
got married yesterday it was a very
eventful wedding you know
like it doesn't work people are just
going to wear
what they were wearing or you know what
they're comfortable with yeah
but i would say there are uh exceptions
to some of these things like maybe there
are cases where the role does involve
um seeing how the candidate handles
uh someone who's being aggressive and
argumentative maybe the role
does involve familiarity uh with some of
the
ide trends plug-ins or maybe the role
does involve someone being dressed in a
particular way
again you should test for these things
but also tell the candidate that that's
what you're testing for like days in
advance
like tell them that's what you're going
to be assessing so they should prepare
for that
uh like you know if you're gonna have a
coding test let them know you're going
to have a coding test if they need to
bring their own laptop
let them know it's yeah it sounds simple
but it
goes wrong in practice quite a lot i
agree and i think
there could be more clarity here as well
in many instances that i've seen but
it's just like
what you're going to test and how you're
going to test it like often you know we
often talk about either white
board interviews which have gotten out
of criticism because
that's not how you do your job like you
don't write code on a whiteboard and i
know how i remember how painful it is to
like
write code write curly braces with a big
marker on a big whiteboard
it's just not how your eye has been
trained on a daily basis to perceive
your own code
and it will just lower your abilities
and even to this day i often end up in a
situation where i have to tell
an interview candidate that you know
they expect people to write their code
in a google doc which is better than on
a whiteboard
but a google doc is not what we are used
to writing code in so
you know google docs doesn't take care
of indentation
or syntax highlighting or any of those
sort of things
and so i always try to be very vocal
about like i understand this is not your
ide don't worry
about you know syntactical errors
misspelled api names
we all know that ides take care of that
for us it's about
talking about the problem knowing that
you have the right solution
often you know we also know that we
google a lot we get help from the
internet which
sometimes in interviews for some reason
is frowned upon which i i technically i
also don't understand
and all these things i think should as
you say should be laid out before and
what are the criteria
why are these criteria there and what
does the loud voice all along
and and most of what you just said on
when it comes to coding questions
uh has just taken care of a big chunk of
my content that's coming up later
apologies we cannot skip my comments no
no that's no we'll keep those in because
i can just skip it later on but and i do
want to talk more
about uh testing for coding but first
i want to just start with the very
beginning of the interview
or even just slightly before the
interview because i would say
make sure the candidate is comfortable
like did they need
a bathroom break uh do they break for
any other reason do they need a drink
some of these are more important when it
comes to on-site interviews than
uh you know vc in interviews uh but
if you have an example we had a
candidate coming to google who
they had to rush because a train was
delayed
so they'd sort of run to the office and
as such they were sweating
and so i just said hey do you want to
take 20 minutes to cool down
and they said yes and i don't know if
they would have asked for that if i
didn't offer it
but it felt important because well i
know how i get in that situation
like i end up in a sweat loop because
i'm sweating because i'm hot
then i start getting embarrassed that
i'm sweating
and eventually just shame ends up
siphoning all of the water out of my
body and i am not going to interview
well
when i'm like that no and that's the
thing if you're running
you know evolutionarily speaking
you are in fight or flight which means
your blood is anywhere in your muscles
but not your brain which will
significantly hurt your chances of using
it correctly and those things
interviewers i think need to be aware of
yeah you want the candidate at their
best so
enable them to be that all right let's
talk about the questions
i would say maybe this is controversial
but use the same questions for each
candidate
like some say i or they prefer more
flowing natural
conversation but i prefer the same
questions because it's a stronger basis
for comparison
it also avoids some unconscious bias
like you can branch off
your questions with follow-ups and that
kind of thing but i would say stick to
the same
core questions for each candidate i i
actually do the same thing i have the
same
question that i've been using for a long
time which actually is helpful because i
know
what my level of expectation should be
like what is the bell curve
of people at different levels how far do
they get
what kind of traps do they run into how
can i recognize early what you know
what holo type of in interview candidate
this is and how can i help them get over
a hump that is
potentially just a retiring to actually
evaluating their actual performance and
capabilities
um so i think that's that's really
really good advice and yeah you can
refine it over time you can
find different branches over time for
people with different skills some people
care about memory optimization some
people care about runtime optimization
some people care about the visualization
and all of these things you can usually
take your problem
down different roads while still
sticking to the original question so you
know
what to expect absolutely but i would
say for the first question
start open-ended and controversial don't
make it a big
technical deep dive like try and ease
the candidate in
i usually go for something like in terms
of work what do you enjoy doing
um or what do you want to focus on in
apologies yeah i was
jumping to technical in like coding
questions but you're right
obviously the interview doesn't
shouldn't start with that actually
because it is very important to
get to know your candidate so and just
you know what kind of person
are you talking to yeah and it just me
it gives them an easy question that they
can answer as well
and so it kind of puts them at ease
i would say especially if you're saying
what do you want to do in the role or do
you enjoy doing
i have seen a lot of candidates um i
would say this
correlates with younger candidates but
it doesn't matter but
it does tend to uh will say something
like oh they'll take an attitude of like
i'll do whatever it takes sir you know
they they're really eager to please and
if that happens
i try and nip that in the bud and say no
like you know here's the things that i
like to focus on here's the things i
don't like
you by example saying look it's it's
okay to have a focus it's okay to have
an opinion on this stuff
and with this question yeah it's mostly
about easing them in but i'm also
looking to see that they fought about
the role
and that they have enough experience to
know the things they enjoy
i mean and this is specific to developer
relations but i always
think developer relations has so many
different facets
right you can you can do the stupid
stuff that we do by doing videos you can
write articles you can write libraries
you can go to conferences
you can communicate more with the
engineering team and help them out set
the right roadmap there's so many
different facets of developer relations
that are
part of the role that actually nobody
can do all of these at the same time
at the at the same level you will be
better at time and you will enjoy some
more than others
and that's exactly what is interesting
actually about candidates where do they
see their strengths and what kind of
part do they actually
know is part of the role which part they
maybe didn't know as part of the role
these are all
interesting conversations to have yes
but no matter what the first question is
there's something else that happens
quite a lot
and that's the candidate has been
thinking about this interview for a
while
they've been thinking of what they're
going to say and the points they want to
get across
and sometimes the question you ask first
doesn't quite match what they were
expecting but they're not going to let
that stop them they're going to give the
answer to the question they wish you
asked instead
and it's tempting to get sarcastic
at this point but again
you're not there to win avoid telling
them off just
let them say their bits and then
rephrase your question
and ask it again yeah and we have
you have to be careful that people are
going to be nervous like they're
potentially they're scared to bits that
they're now
depending on the company have one
interview two interviews five interviews
and they probably want to get the job
otherwise they wouldn't be here
and that might just inhibit them from
parsing the question correctly and
some people need to prepare for an
interview to feel calm
and to be able to get through it and so
it is as you say it is tempting to be
like ha
candidate can't even listen to a
question but
be careful about those kind of
assumptions and i always say if that's
something they do throughout the
interview it's not worthy
that you know they're not great at
listening maybe
and that could be an issue for an
employee but if it's with the first
question
i wouldn't worry about it all right
let's do a little bit of let's do a role
play for this
for this next point summer oh boy
i want you to ask me the question that
is on
the screen all right jake hello
how would you defeat a giant
robot army uh well um
a good question by the way i would build
an even bigger robot
suit and i would
punch all the evil robots in their robot
dicks until they were very sorry about
the whole thing and the planet was saved
well done 10 out of 10 you're hired okay
let's try that again another question
for you
jake so tell me about a time you helped
defeat a giant robot army
i've never done that fired
and if you were looking for someone to
fight giant robots you just learned
something useful
i don't have the experience now
aspirational questions are okay
especially as an opener but if there's a
way to phrase your question that taps
into actual experience i would say
that's usually the better way
like if you ask the candidate how would
you handle a disagreement with a
co-worker
you're asking for a theoretical answer
you'll get you'll get a fantasy answer
and that's not as useful as if you said
tell me about a disagreement you had
with a co-worker and what you did
to resolve it now you're getting
something i punched them in the face
exactly well that's that's an important
thing to learn you want to learn that
if you've got someone violent on your
hands that's something you want to learn
as early as possible
hopefully before hiring them but yeah
you if you're asking for evidence you
learn about their experience you learn
about their attitude
you also learn about their communication
skills through the their telling of the
story
if the candidate doesn't have an answer
um offer them thinking time
if they can't think of anything then say
sure okay
you can give me the theoretical version
what would you do
not very useful to you but at least the
candidate gets
through the question uh which brings me
to my next point
try to avoid making a candidate feel
like a failure like even if they
kind of are like if they flunk a
question try and
try and make it so it they didn't
interviews are stressful and high
pressure
you're trying to get the best out of the
candidate if they struggle with a
question help them through it
even if it becomes useless to you uh in
terms of the interview
at least they feel like they got through
it and they're not taking
negative baggage into the next question
or the next interview
because it could have just been that one
question that they struggle with like
due to nerves they got in a mess
or whatever yeah or you tapped into
their weak spot
in terms of topic these are all like it
could just be
that you as the one interviewer got
unlucky with this candidate in a
specific consolation
and on that note i would also avoid the
typical phrases where you go like oh
that's an
interesting answer because even though
it is sugar-coated
into interview candidates can pick up on
that and then you have just
increased the pressure without even
realizing so try to be genuine
about helping them and actually wanting
them to succeed
also i'd say that if you're expecting
the candidate to say something negative
about themselves
or the company make sure the candidate
knows that's okay
like a lot of candidates are nervous
about this and it'll work against them
what they tend to do is actually say
something positive but like
wrap it as a negative like you know my
problem is i'm too helpful
or i think the problem with the company
is there's no way it can be improved or
something like that
so just let them know hey you know say
something negative about yourself
or you know say that you're looking for
people who
will change things about the company so
you're looking for people with those
kinds of ideas or
so it kind of puts some you're letting
them know it's safe
to say negative things both about
themselves or about the company
okay it's time that we talked about
the coding question which we've sort of
mentioned
you ruined all my content so much no
it's this uh
your points were very good because it's
some of the stuff that i wanted to say
as well
i think it's coding tests are
controversial
i think it's good to assess the
candidate's ability
uh whether a coding exercise is the
right way i don't know for sure
i tend to do a 20 to 30 minute coding
exercise in an interview
as such the questions i use tend to be
simplified compared to real world
equivalence
which is a weakness of that system there
are alternatives i've seen companies do
homework assignments
or longer pair programming sessions um
it's a difficult balance to get right
like something short is short which is
good
something longer can be more realistic
but then it might not be respectful of
the candidate's time like remember
they've got a full-time job so if you're
taking them in for you know a whole day
of job experience essentially one i hope
you're paying them for that but also
you know they've got a full-time job did
they actually you know you're taking a
lot of their time away to do this
on the one hand you know the coding
exercise during an interview
is inherently unrealistic of
an engineering job because you will
spend the entire day
on coding most likely and not just 20
minutes on a problem you have just
discovered where you are
not allowed to google things it is
inherently
unrealistic some companies have you know
tried to make it more realistic by
taking a bigger realistic problem and
giving the candidate a week to take it
home
but as you said that is not only
disrespectful potentially of their time
because they might have a job so they
now have to sacrifice their evenings
but also companies are giving them work
that they could actually use
like that that is useful to them and now
they have interview candidates do work
for them
which is also not fair so it is an
extremely delicate
balance to strike yes and i'm going to
stick to my experience here
uh so the small coding exercise in terms
of that stuff i would say
avoid write this particular algorithm
the infamous invert the binary tree yeah
so instead of
write code to invert this binary tree
present a more real world example
which could be solved by inverting a
binary tree if the candidate realizes
that inverting a binary tree is the
right way to solve the problem
that's like 85 of the problem solved
like in the real world they could look
up
how to invert a binary tree if they
couldn't remember it
the important bit is being able to
connect the the theory with the practice
a lot of candidates they they cram
learn all of these algorithms but
if they can't see a problem and realize
which algorithm they need to use
you know that's that's a gap in their
learning and it's it's something that's
useful to you as an interviewer to find
that out early
because those connections are the most
important thing yeah as a
as a little tip from me as an
interviewer who
to people who take interviews
who interview at companies for me and i
actually i can't i only can speak for
myself
obviously but if you are solving a
problem
and you know there exists an algorithm
or you even know the name but not how it
works
for me it is a 10 out of 10 points
answer if you say
let's assume i have the function called
invert binary tree
and you just call it without imp like
you just use it in your code without
having the implementation
knowing an algorithm of the top of your
hand and how to implement it
to me is not part of the job
unless you are working on i don't know
the the library that is inverting binary
trees and you are interviewing for that
job then yes then that
is part of the job but that is the niche
in the general case
if you know there are solutions and you
can even name them
you get full points from my ends yeah i
would say when i'm interviewing as well
it doesn't matter if they can't name the
algorithm
like if if they write what is inverting
a binary tree
but they never say the words binary tree
or inverting
doesn't matter i don't need someone to
name those things
i would say yeah try and find something
real world as well like maybe a problem
that you solved as part of
the job that they're applying for but of
course if it's something that took you
hours to solve it's not fair to expect
them to solve it in 30 minutes
so would really sort of boil it down to
maybe the
the interesting parts that are solvable
in a short amount of time
uh also try and find something with
multiple phases
it's something that has like a simple
solution that maybe isn't optimal
and then you can build on top of it to
make make it better or make it faster
or make it hit edge cases i strongly
agree with this i
i like problems with multiple solutions
with different
not only complexity but it's a trade-off
and even just having a conversation
about these trade-offs can be very
interesting to assess how much the
candidate has thought about
trade-offs memory trade-off runtime
trade-off code complexity maintenance
trade-off these are all things that you
know matter
usually in in real cases and it helps
you ensure that
as you said earlier feel make the
candidate feel like they're succeeding
because it is the more solutions that
are possible
the more likely it is they will find one
of them and can
help you or can um can explain them to
you and something that actually is
really nice once they found a solution
is something that i often like ask them
to write one or two unit tests
which you know oh that's nice makes them
think about
can can they actually know abstract the
interface can they figure out edge cases
are worth testing
how do they test and all these little
things can be very very interesting to
talk about
yes and if the candidate struggles as
well if you've got a multi-phased
question you can just help them to one
of the phases the next phase
and then call it a day and you know the
candidate feels like
they've achieved something they're not
taking negative energy into the into the
next interview
i would say if you're doing that kind of
thing
be careful you don't scare the candidate
with simplicity
like let them know it's multiple phases
i've seen candidates freeze up
because the start of a question is
relatively simple
they feel it's simple and they're
looking for the gotcha
they're looking for the complicated bit
they haven't spotted but it's not there
um yeah and i've definitely had that one
my one of my old questions
or one of my old series of interview
questions for the coding started with
okay
let's make the tools we need for the
bigger question
what how do you generate a random number
between a and b
and as exactly as you said people froze
up and were wondering like
they had a solution but surely it can't
be that simple and so i i've learned
over time to be like
this is not a trick question we are
building simple tools that we can
put together later on for something way
bigger so just roll with me
yeah i would say i definitely avoid
using the word simple as well
in case that's a very good advice
um i usually say something like if you
think of a solution
but you're unsure whether it's optimal
or complete don't worry about it write
it down
uh it's better to write something down
and then we build upon that
rather than try and get it perfect first
time and end up with nothing which i
have seen
happen in some interviews as well during
these questions helping the candidate is
fine
just make a note of how much help they
needed because that's part of your
assessment
uh again it means they leave the
question hopefully feeling positive as
well
here's here's something that you you
mentioned earlier as well allow them
to use their own laptop don't make them
code on a whiteboard
like if they want to use a whiteboard
that's fine but don't make them
don't make them code in the google doc
and this is me apologizing for every
google interview where this still
happens
i refuse to take part in this even if
the interview advice i'm given is
telling me to use a google doc i don't
because i just don't think it's right
so yes that does still happen i'm sorry
about it no people should be using the
environment that they are comfortable
with
also try not to assess too much at once
if
you're testing the algorithmic problem
solving tell them you're not worried
about variable naming because
it probably doesn't matter you said some
of this stuff before if you do care
about variable naming maybe present them
with some badly written code
and ask them to refactor it to be more
maintainable
because then the algorithm's already
there they don't have to worry about
that they just have to read the code
and make it better also
don't test memory uh you said this as
well allow them to look stuff up
like method names like remembering how
slice works
versus substring in javascript it
doesn't matter i usually tell candidates
to use me as a search engine and they
can ask me questions
and either i'll tell them or i'll look
it up myself because it's good to sort
of hear where they're
what they're thinking and that's a good
way of doing that i whenever i
i've done the same thing i often offer
candidates to use their editor instead
of the
google doc and some candidates still
choose the google doc but you know it's
their choice at that point
um but in in in the editor where i just
ask them to share the screen with me so
i can see what they're doing
and i don't think autocomplete is
cheating not at all like
it is a tool we all use when we work why
would it be cheating
i've seen this a couple of times where
people
you know you're not allowed like it's
more like an exam where they expect you
to know everything on the top of your
head which is just
wildly unrealistic and not in line with
what the job actually looks like we all
make mistakes
more so under interview pressure and if
the candidate has like an off by one
error
is it worth making them sweat over it i
tend to ignore it or
say hey online 12 you've gotten off by
one error
and they'll they'll spot it it's it's
not worth it it's something they would
see in the real world when they ran the
code
i'm not going to show you the coding
question i use because then i'd have to
pick a new one and i like my coding
question too much
but here's the example of the kindest
thing i'm talking about so this would be
aimed at web developers who are expected
to write javascript
uh it's kind of showing can they fetch
some json and append some stuff to the
page
i wouldn't expect them to remember the
dom apis i'm just looking to see if they
know how the dom works
and how async code works because that
that is something that they will have to
do in the real world and then in like a
second phase of the question i'd say
okay our api returns 10 results at a
time you know we'll fix that one day but
in the meantime
we'd like to display 50 results at once
can you make that happen with this api
so now they have to do five fetches um
it tests more advanced
async stuff can they return the stuff in
the right order
uh do they fetch it one by one or do
they fetch it all together
um do they wait until they've got all of
the results before putting any of them
on the page
like these are all little phases they
you know they might choose um
yeah they fetch the first set of results
and then they start fetching the next
one and then you could say to them hey
you know is there any way you could make
this faster by you know well i wouldn't
tell them
by fetching it all at once unless they
needed the hint but see if they could
figure that out themselves like there
are many layers to something like this
um ask them if there are certain user
interactions that might
cause bugs here like could they spot if
the you know the user enters submit
multiple times
before the previous results have come
back you might end up with those sort of
things interleaving
do they know how to handle that you know
do they know how to handle that in an
efficient way
it's a really basic question it's
something that we
tend to do in our jobs quite a lot
fetching some data and displaying it but
even to something like this there are so
many
layers that you can add to see where the
candidates are
yeah and as and as we mentioned earlier
you can take it down many different
paths depending on
where the candidate's strengths are
which hopefully at this point you've
talked to them about if they are
you know more into visualization and you
want to see and that's something that
you actually need on your team as well
maybe you want to change it up and lead
it down that path maybe they can
visualize the in-progress request or
something like that it's nice to have
these questions that are flexible and
you can bend them a little bit to fit
more towards the candidate so you can
make the candidate shine at their
strengths
absolutely and once all that's done you
say goodbye to the candidates
you've still got work to do because you
need to rate the candidate's performance
uh i would say make sure you stick to
what happened in the interview
this comes into play when the candidate
is someone you know
either a friend or like someone of a an
online profile
that you're aware of let's say that
candidate a
performs better than candidate b but you
know candidate b
and you know they didn't show their best
in the interview and you decide
oh they're actually better than
candidate a based on
some other stuff you know but maybe
candidate a wasn't showing their best
either
so it's kind of unfair that you're
you're offering that leeway to candidate
b and not candidate a
i would say if you're unsure do another
round of interviews get them both back
in again
also write your assessment straight
afterwards make notes during the
interview but write up your conclusions
straight away
because your memory doesn't get better
with time no it really doesn't
and i would also say that's something
that i have experienced and therefore do
in my
when i interview as well tell the
candidate that you're taking notes
because especially right now in a
virtual setting
it can often seem like you're not paying
attention you're just chatting with your
work friends while
you're waiting for the candidate to come
up with a solution um because you know
maybe you're a touch typist you can look
the person in the eye while typing
i can that to an extent but often
especially when it's cody things i do
look at my notes
um yeah just make sure the candidate
knows that you are being respectful and
you're listening even if you're not
looking at them and typing i've been on
both sides of the table on that one
i've yeah i felt like i was being
ignored because they were just sort of
looking away going uh-huh tap tap
tap tap tap tap tap tap tap yeah but
they're making notes
that's which is the right thing to do
yeah also
agree on a rating system so each
interviewer is scoring the same way
that that kind of thing really helps
also
come to your conclusion before speaking
to anyone else who is doing the
interview because
group and attitude polarization is a
thing like
even without you knowing it by talking
to someone else your opinion
it might even change but it's more
likely to become more extreme
so record your own viewpoint so when you
discuss it with other interviewers like
you can be persuaded of course
you know they can say well i felt this
and you could you know adjust your own
viewpoint
but make sure you have your initial
viewpoint and make sure that's heard
yeah i think in general biases are a
thing to be aware of and
it can be biases introduced after
interview as you say by talking to other
people be
with without you know somehow writing
down a conclusion first
but also make sure in the interview to
be aware that we as humans
suck at being neutral and open-minded
usually we see a person we have an
opinion somewhere in the subconscious of
our brain
and it can and most likely will affect
how you perceive what they are doing
their gender
their race their earrings all of these
things
can and probably will affect your
evaluation and you need to work hard
to not let them influence you and use
fair criteria
yeah and that's really at the root of
all of these tips
and rules that i've that i've put into
this presentation is
is to just try and avoid bias and avoid
unconscious bias as much as possible it
can't be eliminated but you can
avoid it uh through some of these
methods
but that's all i've got uh but it did
get me a balloon
uh and it also got me some good
teammates as well well well i'm not sure
about that
[Laughter]
focus on the documentation and the
naming
[Music]
i squeaked while i said that make notes
during the interview
but write up the conclusion straight
away because your memory
i can't speak today we're so close to
the end